everyone thank you for joining us on our
latest
installment of zadil
provisions for the hereafter taken from
the
way and tradition of the best of mankind
the prophet muhammad
last session
we discussed a number of things we
wrapped up the issue of
we spoke in detail about wiping over
footwear
we spoke with a level of of detail
with regards to wiping over one's head
garment or dress as well we spoke about
tayemum
and finally we spoke about the way that
the prophet salallahu
we would to just tie up some of
those loose ends
and in my experience there has been a
number of misconceptions
with regards to tayem with regards to
russel that i would to discuss
now when it comes to udo we have to
understand that every
warship is based and built on
pillars and conditions this is what
makes a warship
valid or invalid
pillars and conditions they are
essentially the same thing
with the fukuha it's just that
conditions
are considered outside of the actual
worship and pillars are part of the
actual worship
so for example a pillar
of salah is reciting al-fatiha
a condition of salah
is making wudu right
or rafael more specifically
so we see that making wudu it is a
prerequisite it is a condition but it's
not
actually part of salah right
but reciting surat al-fatiha is a part
of salah this is what the scholars
of filk mean when they say conditions
and pillars that's the only difference
now when it comes to
it has a number of pillars which we
mentioned
we mentioned six pillars of right
we said washing the face including the
mouth and nose
washing the hands and arms
up to include the elbows
wiping over the head including the ears
front and back
washing the feet up to include
the ankles and
that this be done in order and we
discuss that
and that this be done in quick
succession
meaning that we do it all together one
right after the other
without any serious
without any serious gap time wise
now there are things that will
invalidate and this is something that we
need to discuss
many people are unclear as to what
invalidates will
we spoke about this a little bit in our
last
meeting things that invalidate
are anything that comes out of the front
or
back private parts all right
the scholars of philly
another thing is deep sleep
unconsciousness drunkenness
extreme emotion that causes a person to
lose his senses
right likewise
one of the things that will break a
person's will is eating camel meat
and of course there are other things
that the scholars of islam differ on
touching the opposite sex
skin to skin contact
this in the correct opinion of the
scholars of islam
will only invalidate a person's wudu
if he or she has anything that is
any kind of secretions
so if a person becomes sexually aroused
they will have secretions that will come
from their
front private parts men and women
if this happens the will is invalidated
not because of the touch but that will
do is invalidated
because of what has come out of the
private parts
and those are the two main sources of
will do being broken
one of the evidences that the scholars
use for this
is a narration in a sunan and also in
sunnin
on the authority of
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
and on his way out to the masjid to lead
saleh
may kiss one of his wives
and of course kissing a person's wife
this is done not
in a cordial manner this is done
in a romantic way
and that he would kiss any of his wives
and then he would go out to lead salah
another thing that will break a person's
will is
touching his or her private parts
skin on skin now the scholars of islam
differ
on this greatly because there are two
narrations
they differ on these narrations whether
they are authentic or not
and as well they differ on understanding
these narrations
so there is a narration which the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
touches his we will say
whoever touches his male genitalia then
he is to
redo his wudu now the first thing we
need to know about this narration
is that what is meant by touching
is skin on skin this is what is meant by
touching el mises
in the arabic language
in the arabic language touching is not
through garments
not through clothing what's meant by
touching is skin on skin
now this is something which
if a person touches his private parts
skin on skin directly then this will
break a person's will
now what is meant by touching
the private part is for a person to
touch his private parts
up to the wrist right
because perhaps a person is drying off
and they accidentally
bump into their private parts with their
bare skin with their
forearm or something this will not break
a person's wall
rather what breaks a person's will is
touching deliberately some scholars
mention that
it is not only touching but touching
with sexual arousal
and they say the reason for this is that
what
distinguishes a person's private parts
from the rest of his or her body so if i
touch
my hand with my other bare hand this
does not break my wudu
right so why is it that touching the
private parts
will break a person's will well some
scholars of islam have mentioned
that the only thing that distinguishes a
person's
private parts from the rest of his body
is sexual arousal
and that if a person has sexual arousal
then this will break his or her wudu but
if a person does not have sexual arousal
when they touch their
private parts this will not affect his
or her will
and this is a very strong opinion
this is the opinion of many scholars of
islam
and it is one of the opinions of imam
ahmad rahimahullah
with regards to this issue if a person
wishes to be
safe and go ahead and make will do if
they touch their
private parts on purpose or not now
if your own private parts will break
your wudu
right then the private parts of another
would definitely break your wudu right
this is what the scholars of islam
refer to as bab ola
so if my own private parts
me touching them will break my wudu then
of course
touching the private parts of another
would break my wadu
and that is correct but again let's say
a woman
is bathing her son or bathing her
daughter
or changing their child and
their hand
happens to come in contact with their
child's
genitals will this break her wudu
most likely no because there is no
sexual intention there
[Arabic recitation]
now with regards to taiyemum there is
something that i'd to mention
and that is does there need to be
something that is tangibly
tangible and visible on your hands
when you make tayammum right
what does that mean well if i say i am
going to make to yemen does it have to
be
on dust i have to when i raise my hands
up there
is remnants of that dust on my hands
does it have to be visible felt or can
it be
something that is more symbolic and does
not have to be visible
so if a person for instance makes
tayammum on grass
or if a person makes tayammum on sand
this is not going to stick to your hands
there's not going to be anything when
you lift your hands
right contrary to dust well the scholars
of islam differ on this
al-imam ahmad and imam shafir
rahimahullah
they say no it needs to be dust
however
they say no we do it on any surface
because that is the meaning of saeed
in the arabic language saeed as we
mentioned is anything that is a top
of the earth so whether it's the desk or
the wall
or a rock or a stone or sand or
a grassy area this is all considered
tahimum
and that is the closer and more correct
opinion
likewise this is the opinion that sheikh
al-islam even
and endorsed here in this chapter and we
discuss that
in detail we move on to bathing
now we describe the way that the prophet
sallallahu
in the way that he used to bathe
and we mentioned the reasons that he
bathed in that way now
there is something that i'd to
mention that many people misunderstand
for many years i lived in the caribbean
and
there people are constantly swimming in
the ocean swimming in the caribbean sea
and
because of this they may be swimming and
i found that a lot of people
misunderstand what is meant by horses
russell is not just that a person has
covered his entire person with water
that's not what jose is russell can only
be
done and considered russell
that takes the place of wudu
when a person is doing it out of worship
now i'm going to explain what that means
so if a person is in a state of
there are two times when a person must
make wudu
and their salah is not valid until they
make
until they make russell to two times
two types of individuals their solar
cannot be accepted
until they have made russell they have
bathed
that is the one who is in a state of
sexual impurity
or the one who is
finished with her menstruation or or
postpartum bleeding
menstruation and postpartum bleeding
they have both
the exact same rulings in all of the
legislation of islam
except for three instances and this is
not one of them
and so if a person is in a state of
sexual
impurity what does that mean well
it frankly means ejaculation
whenever there is the expulsion of semen
or for the woman that sexual release
that is accompanied with
that orgasmic release as the scholars of
islam say
it is pushed out with that sexual
drive whether it is male or female
now the person must make russian
so this applies to all of us
let's say a person goes to sleep and
this is a question
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was asked
by some of the women in his time
and that is let's say a person goes to
sleep and he has
dreams of sexual nature
during this sleep and the person
feels that they have
had this
this sexual climax or or whatever
and the person wakes up and they
remember that dream
do they have to make russell or not
well the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was actually asked this
question
and he responded in
he was asked by a woman if a woman has
dreams of a sexual nature does she need
to make
russell when she wakes up he said in
the tillman if ejaculate has been
expelled from the body
then yes if semen has been
has has come out of the person's body
then yes
if not then no right
now this is a time when a person is in
sexual
impurity there's a spiritual impurity
and a person has to make listen
likewise if a man and a woman
have intercourse even if there is no
climax or ejaculation right
as long as there is penetration that is
it a person has to make listen
now we are getting into some of these
details that may be uncomfortable for
certain people it's certainly
uncomfortable for me anytime i speak
about it but it is necessary a lot of
people
don't understand these rulings because
they're too shy to ask or they think
that it is
something which is not something that
should be talked about or spoken about
with such candidness and that is
not correct the only way we can learn is
if we ask
and if we delve into these things
some of the taberine had said two types
of people will never learn
two types of people will never learn
those who are too shy to ask
questions and those who who are too
arrogant
to ask questions and so we can't let
this
borrow us from learning our religion
under the guise of modesty
this is not modesty which is
commendable
the second type of hustle is a woman who
has had her menstruation cycle
it is completed now she is to bathe
likewise postpartum bleeding
which is something we should mention the
day the amount of time for postpartum
bleeding
is 40 days 40 days
what does that mean it doesn't mean that
it has to be
at least 40 days that means it has to be
at most 40 days so a woman gives
birth and she has postpartum bleeding
for two weeks
and then it dries up and stops now she
is to make russell and
proceed with her warship as usual but
let's say she has her postpartum
bleeding for
more than 40 days we say no at the day
of 40
now we start even though the blood is
still coming out
now this has become a different thing
this is no longer considered postpartum
bleeding
this is no longer nefess
when a person is in this state
sexual impurity or a person is in a
state of
menstruation or postpartum bleeding
russell
for women only and they go to make
at this moment they do not have to make
russell
and then make wudu this is actually
incorrect
specifically pointed out
he would never make wudu after making
hustle
and so if a person has the intention
of making russell because he is in a
state of sexual impurity or because she
is in a state of postpartum
or menstruation that is over they are
now bathing
yeah only bathing bathing itself
will take the place of wudu as
that which alleviates major
spiritual impurity will alleviate that
which is minor
meaning if a person is in a state of
sexual impurity
likewise that which is less impurity
like
using the restroom or passing gas or any
of these lesser things
this will take its place and so
a lot of people you know they're at
the beach they're
bathing or whatever it is and or what
this happens
a lot people get up in the morning while
most of us we take showers in the
morning before
before we go to work and so a common
common mistake that i've seen
is that people will take a shower
and not make wudu and expect that that
shower which is not a religious shower
it's not a spiritual shower you're not
taking that bath or that shower as a
worship of allah that is a customary
thing
right this is
and they just take a shower and they
proceed with their day not having made
wudu
and think that they have will do because
they took a shower
that is very incorrect the only time a
shower
what we say a shower bathing will take
the place of
is if a person is in a state of geneva
or if a person is in a state of
a person has the intention of taking a
shower for geneva which is sexual
impurity
that now is a warship and that is
binding and obligatory that will take
the place of
but just your customary i showered in
the morning that cannot take the place
of
you have to take you have to make wudu
because there is a difference that goes
on with persons intentions
and a difference of opinion amongst the
scholars
likewise the russell of jummah some
scholars say
if you take the russell of jumu' that
will take
the place of wudu that is a strong
opinion
but that is only a valid opinion if we
consider that rusli
is obligatory right so
better that we keep it to be safe with
us
if a person takes russia bathes
to get rid to lift the headeth
of major sexual impurity geneva
or because it is menstrual menstruation
or
from postpartum then and only then
will that take the place of wudu
we mentioned that the way that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
make russell
is that he is
that he would begin with washing his
hands
then he would wash his front and back
genitals private parts and then he would
make
regular wudu just you would make
will
forsala after this he would pour the
water on his head
three times and work the water
to his scalp after
this he would bathe the right side of
his body
and then he would bathe the left side
of his body
and then he would conclude with his two
feet
we mentioned that this is the sunnah
that a person should
adopt when taking russell
when making when bathing right
but the bare minimum of russell
is that a person have the intention of
russell
with the water coming in contact with
every part of his or her skin
head to foot including a person's
scalp
and the mouth and nose in whatever order
that happens
you just stand under the shower head it
covers all of your
body or front and back private parts
then this will suffice as a hustle
that's the bare minimum but that's not
necessarily the sunnah the sunnah is the
way that aisha described to us
[Silence]
he says this chapter is regarding the
way
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would make salah
would pray again
when it comes to these issues many
people
are going to differ on whether
these things are the intricacies
i want to mention something that many
people misunderstand
and it actually it is a very dangerous
concept that a lot of people have
about islam and its clarity
this is that the majority of islam
the majority of islamic law
the majority of islamic
obligations and prohibitions those
things which are recommended and those
things which are
those things which are discouraged
right the majority
80 percent
90 of all of these things
are issues that have been agreed upon
amongst the scholars of islam
the things that they differ on are
intricacies
that do not have to do with the
integral structure of these things
what does that mean
a lot of people when they pick up a book
of fake or they start
especially those who are trying to learn
islam in a more deep
fashion and they read the words and the
books of the scholars of islam
they come under this opinion that
everything is an issue that is a
difference of opinion
everything everything is a difference of
opinion
and the things which the scholars agree
on
is actually they are very limited and
that's exactly the opposite of what is
true
most things are agreed upon
alhamdulillah because
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he has said
with regards to this he says
[Silence]
i have left you all
on the clearest of paths meaning paths
to allah subhanahu wa
he said this path that i have left you
all upon
is so clear that its night
is just as bright and clear as its
daytime
the only person who will deviate from
this path
is one who is upon destruction
one who is upon deliberate misguidance
right and so
islam is clear the majority of
all of islamic law and prohibitions and
obligations
is clear a person may think well how is
that
for instance the amount of prayers a day
is agreed upon
the amount of in every prayer is agreed
upon
urukur comes before sujud every unit of
prayer has one rukur and two sujud
tashahud facing the qibla for instance
all of these things are issues that have
been agreed upon amongst the scholars of
islam
right the things that are differed
upon is are the are the
details some of the more minutiae
such as where to hold the hands
the right hand over the left which is
the majority of the scholarship of islam
have agreed is the sunna
and where these hands should be placed
should it be right here
should it be between the navel in the
chest should it be on the navel below
the navel
but we all agree that the person should
place his hands
on his right hand over the left hand
nobody came and said it should be the
left hand
over the right hand or for example
that a person should stand facing the
qibla nobody has disagreed on this
or that the fasting of the month of
ramadan is a pillar of islam
and that fasting is from the break of
dawn until the
sun set and that those things which
break a person's fast are
deliberate eating and drinking and
sexual intercourse
these are things that are agreed upon
the most scholars of islam
the difference of opinion comes in the
the very
fine details and that is that we have to
understand something
as a matter of fact scholars of islam
have written books
with regards to why the scholars of
islam
differ on certain rulings so for example
sheikh
islam even allah he
wrote a book called
he has a treat he's very short book
which he
has entitled lifting
any blame
from the scholars of islam and what he
set out to articulate in this book
is that why would a scholar of islam
purposely
adopt a ruling or adopt an opinion
that directly contradicts a verse of the
quran or sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
right this is this is what that book was
about
very good book and he mentioned six
six different things
that different different factors six
factors that may contribute
to what to us in hindsight
would seem to be that this scholar has
directly
contradicted a clear narration of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
meaning the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam says yes and this
scholar says no why is that why does
that happen it does happen
it is anomalous but why does it happen
well he mentions
six excuses for that the first excuse is
the scholar may just not know that
narration
and that's very plausible not only is
that plausible
but it is highly possible
right it is highly possible and he
begins that book
with mentioning the instances in which
abu bakr al-sadiq who was the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's friend and companion
before islam i mean he was his friend
and his close confidant before he even
became a prophet
i mean if anybody knows the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
even better than his wives because
he is the sole companion who spent the
most
time with the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi and from this the
scholars of islam such as
mentioned that abu bakr al-sadiq is the
most
knowledgeable companion from amongst all
of the companions
but there are instances albeit few
in which he was unaware of a narration
and he was informed of this narration by
others of the companions who have much
less time
spent with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
he mentions
instances in which was
unaware of the narration and was told by
other companions who had become muslim
way
later such as abu musa al-ashadi
uthman ibn afan
he mentions 40 authentic instances
throughout his khilafah and life in
which ali
was unaware of the narration the
statement of the prophet salallahu
why is that were they slacking off were
they not trying to learn
no it's just that as imam hashef
so eloquently said
[Silence]
whoever claims that he knows all of the
sunnah
has made a very incorrect statement
he says nobody knows all of the sunnah
from amongst mankind except for the
prophet muhammad
so it's just not possible the body of
information
is too vast and for us to say that yes
this scholar knows every single
narration
every single they may even know the
narration they just don't
they they haven't noticed the
that it is an evidence for that
particular thing that they are
mentioning
they may not know the narration they may
not grade the narration authentic
they may not understand the narration as
others have understood it
they may have seen that other things
contradict that narration right so there
are reasons
our issue is not to worship scholars we
don't worship scholars
we don't holify them we don't
view them as infallible saints no that's
not correct
a scholar's job is merely to
deliver the information
and to explain it to us that's it a
scholar does not
make up new rules new laws he doesn't
have any
special powers a scholar's position
is to articulate
and pass down what the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam brought to us
and a scholar's position is to explain
what we are unaware of or unsure of
that's it
and a scholar can make a mistake
it's not the norm it's improbable
if the scholar is worth his salt
but it is something that happens with
everyone
because we are human beings yes the
entirety of the sunnah
is entirely preserved
and known to all of the ummah at once as
a whole
yes but to one individual
no the knowledge is too vast
and so in conclusion when we discuss
the prayer of the prophet salallahu said
there's going to be a lot of oh i didn't
hear it that way
i heard it a different way i learned it
a different way
ibn clayem doesn't even get into that he
is now going to just
transmit to us what was authentically
reported
and anything that was not authentically
reported he doesn't even mention
right and so we are going to learn that
and this is why we chose this book
so that is enough for our session
today
insha allah or tonight insha allah
next week we will continue on and we
will begin to discuss in detail
the way that the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
in front of his lord subhanahu wa'ta'ala
we ask allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala that he
bless us beneficial knowledge that he
teach us
of his revelations what we are ignorant
of that he remind us what we have been
made to forget
and that he benefit us with
understanding
and knowledge and action from this
[Arabic recitation]